with the Mandalorians second chapter we
dive a little deeper than ever before
into the state of the galaxy immediately
following the fall of the Empire while
the lot has changed some things stay the
same here are a few of the best
callbacks why the beginning of chapter 2
the Mandalorian is trying to get the
assets a creature that appears to be
some kind of adorable baby Yoda back to
his mysterious client a remnant of the
crumbling Empire but it's a treacherous
and violent journey this trip includes a
run-in with jawless a race of creature
very recognizable to Star Wars fans
visually distinct because of their
hooded cloaks short stature and glowing
eyes and also their tendency to steal
anything that isn't nailed down after
they stripped down his ship the Razer
quest the Mandalorian blasts away any
jours are getting his path on a violent
mission to get his stuff back telling
them to dust as they puff away without
any trace later on Kuo remarks to the
Mandalorian that the creatures really
don't like him for some reason the
Mandalorian applies well it did
disintegrate a few of them this subtly
calls back to a brief exchange in the
Empire Strikes Back
between Darth Vader and the collection
of dicey looking bounty hunters in waste
sucess Lord tells him that he wants to
crew other Millennium Falcon brought to
him alive by any means necessary
and the dressing Boba Fett's Vader makes
a point of specifying no disintegrations
in other words these Mandalorian bounty
hunters just love blasting their enemies
in the pace and are probably known to do
so when given the chance and the while
we're talking about fancy Mandalorian
weapons it's pretty nice to see that
wrist mounted flamethrower make an
appearance can jet packs be too far
behind while the full identity of the
assets is not clear by the end of the
second chapter of the Mandalorian it's
obvious to anyone with even a passing
familiarity of Star Wars that the little
guy is a very young version of a Yoda
type alien probably designed to be a
best-selling toy this Christmas while
this creature with no name is reportedly
fifty years old he's still baby like in
many ways but at the same time very wise
and Yoda like in others specifically he
can definitely use the Force
even without apparently going through
years of fancy Jedi training he lives a
gigantic mud horn off the ground
bit of effort nothing like that time
when Yoda thought real hard and left did
Luke's x-wing whites out of the swamps
of Dagobah the force takes many forms
including healing abilities and this
tiny Yoda successor may also have that
power as seen when he attempts to heal
the Mandalorians wound the great obi-wan
Kenobi may have used his ability to help
Luke would cover from the Tuscan Raider
attack in a new hope but the ability to
heal with the Force has been a bit iffy
and weirdly defined in Star Wars Canon
until now and it also begs the question
I notice people just naturally super
strong with the force
it's hard to tell endure all the special
effects are making like an ignored but
quill the Mandalorians Ally friends and
lifesaver is portrayed by three-time
Oscar nominated actor Nick Nolte who
brings his specific world-weary style of
acting to the loner alien but really
quilt doesn't have to work alone if he
doesn't want to after they've escaped a
whole lot of trouble in Chapter two of
the series the Mandalorian suggests
making their relationship a bit more
permanent
he offers quill a well-paid spot on his
crew Burke will respectfully rejects it
I am honored but I have worked a
lifetime to finally be free of servitude
that's a weighty statement but his
reasoning can be traced back to the
Empire Strikes Back and a visit to Cloud
City ignored her briefly depicted as the
industrious backbone of our society
hired because of their work ethic and
given a home after their planet was
decimated by slavery according to
official Star Wars law as a man who was
once without a home in the galaxy
leaving behind his hard-earned patch of
land just doesn't seem like the better
option check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos of other Mandalorian are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and to the bail so you don't miss a
single one
you